these sweeping Landscapes and
picturesque views of Ukraine Before the
War as president philodi mirzelenski
gave a special video address for Unity
day commemorating modern Ukraine's
formation more than a century ago
across Ukraine in the summer in the
autumn in the winter we are defending
all this together and we will win
together and the entire Ukraine will
hear the sounds of a victory or true or
shell crane
since Russia invaded ukrainians have
come together to defend their country
for some Unity day is a fitting symbol
for a shared experience
it's our independence and autonomy that
unite us for me this day means we are
together and defending our values with
our lives
caves pass on bridge spans the danipro
river it's usually at the center of the
city's Unity Day Celebrations but
officials are worried about security
traditionally on Unity day people would
form a human chain across this bridge
but Ukrainian officials have canceled
the event this year because of the war
to Mark the day former British prime
minister Boris Johnson made a surprise
visit to Ukraine he met president
zielinski and visited the town of
Butcher on the capital's outskirts
hundreds of people were killed in
butcher under Russian occupation in
March last year
well I can tell you that the the UK will
be sticking by Ukraine for as long as it
takes
you are going to you are going to win
and you're going to get all the Russians
out of your country but we will be that
uh for the long term
[Music]
Johnson's visit comes as Western Powers
have promised more weapons for Kiev and
Prussia continues to build on Germany to
allow its leopard tanks to be sent to
Ukraine
Kiev says it needs all the Firepower he
can get to defend itself most people
here agree for nearly a year now
ukrainians have shown what Unity can
look like and how powerful it can be
Natasha Butler Al Jazeera Kiev